tenemos aquí una función que se ve
bastante complicada y en realidad esta
función tiene una entrada de dos
dimensiones verdad en realidad tenemos
dos coordenadas como entrada y tenemos
una salida en tres dimensiones verdad
específicamente este es un vector en
tres dimensiones
y cada una de estas expresiones verdad
es un montón de cosas que tienen cosenos
y senos y que dependen de nuestras dos
entradas verdad y en el último vídeo
hablamos de cómo visualizar funciones
que tienen una sola entrada pero tienen
una salida multidimensional y en el
ejemplo que vimos en el vídeo anterior
era algo que tenía dos salidas verdad es
decir su salida era un vector de dos de
dos coordenadas verdad y teníamos en
nuestro parámetro t entonces vamos a
hacer en este vídeo digamos como un
análogo en tres dimensiones de esto que
vimos en el vídeo anterior y lo que
vamos a hacer es simplemente tratar de
visualizar cosas en el espacio de salida
es verdad y vamos a tratar de pensar en
todos los posibles puntos
ser salidas muy bien entonces vamos
vamos a borrar esto y vamos a borrar
esto por ahora así que por ejemplo vamos
a empezar a tratar de obtener cierta
intuición de esta función al evaluarlo
en un par de puntos así que digamos
digamos que vamos a evaluar esta función
efe en el punto cero y entonces vamos a
tomar el punto cero coma pi y vamos a
tratar de evaluar esta función en ese
punto así que veamos a que cuanto vale
esto al evaluar en cero coma y entonces
si nosotros nos regresamos a nuestra
función coseno de cero
valdría uno verdad lo mismo ocurriría
kiko seno es cero
vale uno seno de cero aquí vale cero
verdad el seno de cero es cero lo mismo
ocurriría aquí y ahora vamos a ver qué
ocurre con digamos el parámetro ese
entonces coseno de pi vale menos uno
coseno de pi vale menos uno
seno de pi vale 0 entonces con esto ya
podríamos determinar fácilmente quién es
el digamos el valor de salida de nuestra
función
entonces en nuestra primera coordenada
tendremos 3 x 1 que es 3
1 x menos 1 que es menos 1 entonces 3
menos uno nos da 2 verdad en la segunda
tendremos 0 + 0 x menos 1 todo eso nos
da 0 y en la tercera simplemente
tendremos 0 verdad aquí tenemos nuestro
vector de salida verdad esta salida será
el punto que se encuentra digamos a lo
largo del eje x y simplemente bueno a
dos unidades del origen verdad así que
podemos verlo en esta gráfica agregamos
el punto aquí y eso es lo que
corresponde a este particular a esta
entrada particular verdad la entrada 0
pi y podríamos hacer esto mismo con un
montón de de entradas verdad simplemente
podríamos agregar muchos otros puntos
pero en realidad esto tomaría mucho
tiempo verdad así que para empezar a
obtener cierta intuición de lo que nos
está diciendo la función digamos como un
todo es por otra cosa que podríamos
hacer para esto es en vez de ir pensando
en evaluar punto por punto imaginemos
que tenemos una de las
las constantes así que vamos a imaginar
déjenme déjenme ir borrando todo esto
vamos a imaginar ahora que tenemos
nuestra coordenada ese constante muy
bien entonces mientras borramos esto
vamos a pensar que tenemos nuestra
nuestra entrada ese constante ahora
vamos a dejar que nuestro parámetro t
sea libre entonces cómo es que vamos a
poder estudiar esta función de hecho
para poder estudiarlo vamos a borrar
todo esto también dado que el parámetro
s es constante vamos a dejar eso ahí muy
bien y ahora vamos a poner vamos a
empezar a variar libremente en nuestro
parámetro de muy bien entonces
efe dt coma pi sería quien vamos a
ponerlo con blanco
entonces quién será esto tendremos tres
veces el coseno dt vamos a utilizar los
mismos colores tres veces el coseno de t
y luego tenemos menos uno por coseno de
t así que esto es menos el coseno de t -
el coseno de t y ahí tenemos nuestra
primera coordenada veamos quién sería la
segunda coordenada tendríamos tres veces
el seno de t
tres veces el seno de t
y ahora tenemos menos uno por el seno de
t entonces esto es menos el seno de t
sigamos siendo congruentes con los
colores y finalmente tenemos el seno de
ese que en este caso es pi así que
tendremos que esto vale cero y como
podemos ver esto todavía se puede
simplificar tres veces el coseno de t -
el coseno dt nos da dos veces el coseno
de t
lo mismo ocurre aquí verdad tres veces
seno de t menos seno de t nos da dos
veces seno de t entonces en realidad
todo esto es dos veces el coseno dt
dt aquí vamos a omitir y el color seno
de t
y luego 0 así que todo esto se
simplificó en esto que acabamos de
escribir y otra vez cuando dejamos
digamos este ese constante y le damos el
valor pi y digamos dejamos libremente el
parámetro de entonces obtenemos esto
verdad que en esencia es un círculo y es
lo que estamos dibujando y en realidad
puedes darte cuenta porque es un círculo
verdad tenemos digamos este patrón de
cosenos y senos en realidad es un
círculo de radio 2 y ahora vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo pero en lugar de
pensar en qué ocurriría cuando te varía
ahora vamos a hacer que ese varíe muy
bien entonces en este caso yo te invito
a que trabajes por tu propia cuenta con
esta idea vamos a poner fijo a te vamos
a hacer que te valga cero y que ahora
nuestro parámetro que será libre es el
parámetro s muy bien y vamos a tratar de
dibujarlo y no lo quiero hacer yo porque
quiero que obtengas la intuición tú
mismo
así que en este caso vamos a obtener un
círculo verdad que se ve más o menos de
esta forma otra vez te invito a que tú
trates de pensar porque es que tenemos
este círculo verdad y esencialmente son
digamos los mismos argumentos que ya
hemos realizado así que imaginemos que
dejamos a ese libre manteniendo a t
constante en el valor cero y ahora bien
si nosotros pensamos en dejar digamos
libres tanto el parámetro t como el
parámetro s una forma muy bonita de
visualizar esto es imaginamos que este
círculo digamos representado por por la
s digamos libre que hemos pintado
anteriormente digamos está siendo
barrido a través del espacio que
pintamos cuando tenemos a t corriendo
libremente y en esencia vamos a obtener
esta figura que puedes ver que es como
una dona verdad y tenemos una palabra
elegante para para las zonas en
matemáticas y las llamamos toros muy
bien así que resulta ser que esta
función que tenemos aquí arriba es una
forma elegante de
escribir un toro o una dona verdad y en
otro vídeo voy a digamos entrar más en
detalle por ejemplo si nos dieran el
toro nuestra figura del toro cómo
podríamos encontrar esta función que
tenemos aquí digamos como podríamos
obtener la intuición para obtener esa
función y en realidad nos vamos a
involucrar mucho en ese problema
digamos vamos a retomar la idea de que
estamos barriendo un círculo para
obtener el toro verdad y digamos veremos
cuál es la relación entre el círculo
rojo y el círculo azul pero aquí
simplemente quise darles una intuición
de qué son las superficies
parametrizados verdad de qué se trata
este tema cómo se puede visualizar
digamos una función que tiene una
entrada de dos dimensiones con salida en
tres dimensiones